on va revenir sur l'image du jour alors
bon on rigole beaucoup depuis début de
l'émission
là c'est une belle image puisque hier
sont près de 20000 personnes qui se sont
réunies pour rendre hommage à adama
traoré et dénoncer les violences
policières cette manifestation était
interdite par la préfecture mais a réuni
énormément monde
alors bien sûr on entend qu'il ya eu des
tensions par six détentions par la
menoua là on est on est pas là dedans ce
que les tensions voilà c'est ça ce cas
concerne un petit groupe de personnes
on veut simplement vous montrer le
positif voilà de ce qui s'est passé hier
regardez c'est l'image de ses quatre
copains
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui était ce par la suède aux
états unis qui est notre frère s'était
prudemment flex face aux états unis
années aujourd'hui en lumière ce qui se
passe en france
voilà donc c'est vrai que l'événement
hier soir oui j'ai envie il faut
préciser chez la réunion a été interdite
par la préfecture s'était pas produit à
cause de la cause s'est passé pour cause
de corona que les rassemblements sont
interdits pour sa terre natale pas à
cause de la corée a causé et nabeul et
franchement moi je pense très fort à la
famille mieux d'adama traoré et à tous
ses potes voilà j'en connais en plus
certain et voilà et c'est vrai que mon
cv avec ce qui se passe aux états unis
en ce moment on pouvait pas s'empêcher
de faire le parallèle dans lequel en
cours et c'est là qu'on saura bientôt le
ver est exactement oui bernard sont des
enquêtes différentes mais il est vrai
que toute façon c'est un drame de toute
façon que encore à notre époque en 2020
on soit obligé de se battre pour éviter
effacer les différences entre les races
ou entouré les les couleurs de peau je
trouve ça très triste moi je comprends
ce combat évidemment cette famille
meurtrie tous ceux autour se sentent
concernés et se sentent solidaires
c'est normal c'est très moi je touche je
suis très touché par cet engagement là
ils ont raison même si les deux affaires
sont très différentes de toute façon
faut pas l'oublier et qui est une
histoire de contre expertise et ses
terres en france dans le détail lingua
qu'il en soit cette la soeur de traoré
qui se bat je la trouve magnifique
s'être beau combat
mais évidemment les déférer devant qui a
eu après faut vraiment les condamnés
parce qu'il ya toujours des connards ils
savaient qu'ils s'installent dans les
devises immoral sans faire exprès
numérique pour pour moi ya pas d adresse
et voilà c'est pas non mais bien sûr
voilà donc serait donc voilà on voulait
vous montrer ça c'était l'image du jour
et bravo à tous ceux qui ont parlé ça
mais l'énorme pas s'il ya autour d'une
réunion je sais qu'il y avait moi c'est
vrai que je lui ai dit de ne pas y aller
parce qu'elles étaient interdites et je
me suis dis en tant que maman qu'elle
était ma responsabilité du maire d'aller
dans un rassemblement qui est interdit
donc jaj appréhender et elle m'en a
beaucoup voulu parce que vous l'avez dit
ça a été extrêmement digne les gens
étaient extrêmes on sort des c'était
très beau les images des clichés tous
étaient et je regrette effectivement je
me dis bah peut-être qu'elle aurait dû y
aller mais bon elle ira alors son chèque
même à 19 heures hier on aurait bien
aimé y aller ici mais voilà vous
on était avec eux voient là et on
soutient voilà toute la famille traoré